hier nun zugeschaltet oliver rein wird
und gastronom aus münchen
ich weiß jetzt schon dass sie gesagt
haben dass das jetzt gerade steinzeit
politik ist die hier in deutschland
geführt wird was genau meinen sie damit
so ist es das sehe ich auch so danke
dass ich dabei sein darf ja im grunde
genommen
ich habe meinen daten seit 17 jahren in
münchen und mein klient ist im schnitt
zwischen 18 und 25 und ich habe das in
der ersten welle gesehen da war die
bereitschaft sich an dinge zu halten die
die bundesregierung entschieden hat
schon sehr hoch auch die herr söder oder
herr reiter entschieden hat und je
länger es ging und je sind freier diese
entscheidungen wurden desto mehr sinkt
die akzeptanz bei der jugend und ich
finde das sehr sehr gefährlich und
gerade jetzt mit den neuen dingen die
ihr aufkommen die gerade diskutiert
werden in denen weder riechen sehen
sehen noch viele meiner gäste glaube ich
sehr sehr gefährlich dass es in der
gesellschaft kippen wird und das ist ein
völlig falsches signal ist die
gastronomie einzugrenzen und es geht mir
im grunde genommen nicht um die
gastronomie ich lebe jetzt gott sei dank
nicht nur von meinem laden ich habe noch
andere unternehmen aber deswegen kann
ich so frei sprechen und muss aber sagen
die gastronomie ist ein bereich wo wir
perfekt nachvollziehen können wer da war
also gerade in meinem laden ist es so
dass wir jeden ausweis kontrollieren
schon lange bevor die bundesregierung
überhaupt diese frage gestellt hat am
anfang hieß es
er legt den leuten einen zettel hin die
sollen ihn ausfüllen ja aber es schaut
nicht unbedingt drauf was sie
geschrieben haben weil das ist jeder
datenschutz
wissen sie wie oft der herr söder bei
mir zu gast war oder die frau merkel die
wurde nur getoppt von herrn trump und da
muss ich ganz ehrlich machen es ist doch
ein falsches signal man kann doch von
vornherein sagen leute gastronomen
kontrolliert ihr müsst den ausweis
kontrollieren ohne ausweis kein einlass
damit habe ich eine hundertprozentige
nachverfolgen
dann habe ich hier an der kasse wenn die
leute reinkommen kriegt jeder von mir
lückenlos der fsb zweimaster die zahlen
hier fünf euro servicegebühr und dafür
ist die drei mal gezahlt ich meine das
weiß man heute von den preisen her und
dann habe ich nicht diese komischen
stofffetzen die jetzt auch gerade anhalt
wollen dass die virologen auch sagen die
gar nichts bringen da habe ich eine
gewisse sicherheit dann haben wir hier
in gläser protokoll
das bedeutet also wenn man auch mit
biologen spricht eine große
ansteckungsgefahr besteht in den gläsern
denn dieser virus
nur kaputt wenn man bei mindestens 90
grad west was die wenigsten gastro
spülmaschinen schaffen ja dann muss ich
halt so viele leser auf vorrat haben was
ich garantieren kann dass der gast nur
einmal dieses glas am abend bekommt oder
die gesamten gäste dafür haben die
gläser protokolle also was ich damit
sagen möchte auch wenn man hier die box
sieht in der ich hier sitze es gibt
möglichkeiten in der zusammenarbeit mit
der gastronomie respektive mit dem
bürger wie sich auch die politik
wissenschaft erhalten könnte und nur da
oben zu stehen und zu sagen ich bin
allwissend und dann aber im gleichen
satz zu sagen eigentlich wissen wenn ich
was wir tun bei uns trifft es genau wie
euch aber uns dann nicht zu fragen ob
wohl wer in der demokratie leben
das finde ich falsch finde ich fatal und
ich glaube das wird am ende des tages
ein fehler sein gesicht zu diskutieren
gibt sondern sich sehr sehr viele
politiker entschuldigen müssen nur
bringt das mir und meinen kollegen nicht
die dann nachher auf der straße stehen
und ein herr söder und eine frau merkel
sollten sich mal wie viele andere
staatsmänner überlegen das warum fahre
ich denn im urlaub warum komme ich denn
das schöne land warum komme ich in der
schönen nach münchen weil ich den söder
besuchen möchten ein
ich möchte einig die herzliche
gastronomie erleben ich möchte dass es
herzliche miteinander erleben
es gibt viele möglichkeiten die man tun
könnte die masken schlicht an den
öffentlichen orten ich glaube jeder
sieht das album voll an
aber in bereichen gerade der gastronomie
wo man miteinander ein schutzkonzept
erzielen und aufziehen kann was zu 100
nachvollziehbar ist oder nachvollziehen
lässt wer da war ich glaube es ist der
bessere weg dort sogar mehr zu öffnen
als zu schließen
denn die jugend wird deswegen nicht zu
hause bleiben und um zehn ins bett gehen
sondern die werden privat feiern und da
ist nach unten deswegen sehe ich es als
völlig sinnfrei an
und ja und deswegen hatte ich das gesagt
mit der stadtpolitik wir sind bild und
wir liefern dir deine news auf youtube
zum nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren